iraq's prime minister is calling for
calm following an attempt to assassinate
him
seven bodyguards were injured in a blast
at his home in the heavily fortified
green zone in central baghdad the iraqi
capital was already tense after a
disputed election
[Applause]
gunfire heard from baghdad's green zone
early on sunday morning
diplomats based nearby said they heard
explosions
state television aired these photos
showing the damage to the prime
minister's residence
it was apparently targeted by an
explosive zlatan drone
mustafa al-khadimi was unhurt in what
the iraqi military called an attempted
assassination
my house was the target of a cowardly
attack
but thanks to god i and those who work
with me are in good health
our security and military forces are
working on protecting iraq and its
stability
cowardly rockets and drone attacks do
not build countries and don't build a
future
we are working on building our homeland
by respecting the state and its
institutions and by building a better
future for all iraqis
baghdad's heavily guarded green zone has
been at the center of unrest following
iraq's election last month
iran-backed shia militias have been
camped out nearby after losing much of
their parliamentary power in the vote
they allege voting and counting
irregularities though eu observers have
rejected those claims
on friday protests over the results
turned violent
security forces used tear gas and live
rounds when demonstrators tried to enter
the green zone
witnesses said two protesters were
killed and dozens injured
the attempted attack on prime minister
al-khadimi marks another escalation no
group has claimed responsibility but
experts point to the pro-iran militias
the problem is with these groups and
this has been the situation for the last
year and a half is
when they see that the prime minister is
not willing to be more aggressive they
tend to they tend to escalate at the
same time if the prime minister attempts
to
take a step against them um and show
some force
he sees at some point that he is not
able they are too entrenched in the
security forces they have too much
influence
as tensions saw some fear the stage
could be set for a bloody confrontation
and for more on this i'm joined now from
baghdad by journalist sophia niti sophia
is there any indication of who could be
behind this attack
good morning nick no there is no group
that immediately claimed the
responsibility for this attack but all
the eyes are turned toward the armed
iran-aligned sheer militias who have
been protesting as you explained before
since weeks here in baghdad so it's been
almost one month since the parliamentary
election took place on october 10 which
was almost
violence-free vote and without major
technical glitches but still following
this vote these militia supporters
pitched tenths near the green zone not
far from here and they rejected the
result of this election so they
threatened violence toward the prime
minister unless their demand for a
recount were met so the situation is
that those militias lost many many votes
following on these elections they got
less than 20 compared to around 50 in
the last vote and as you explained
before the situation escalated further
on friday with dozens of security forces
injured here in baghdad and with
additional threatens to the prime
minister mustafa academy
and the prime minister um is calling for
restraint
is anybody going to listen
well he already called for its train
many many times before each time there
is a threaten from the militias or the
militia storm on the green zone he calls
for an appeasement but as we saw uh
nothing changed so far not even after
the election so um it happened several
times before once he tried to to hold a
strong line uh arresting a leader of
shia militia's question mostly in last
june but after a few days he had to cave
and to release this militia leader
because the militia stormed on the green
zone once sitting again so of course he
tries but he lacks national support and
he lacks of um of resources to appease
the situation
and just for the bigger picture will
iraq be able to form a government people
recognize as legitimate if the losing
parties in the last elections continue
to reject the results
well it's still early to to understand
this because the negotiations following
the result of the election are still
ongoing so uh for for what we know uh so
far the big winner of this election is
the same as the 2018 vote so uh mokta
al-sadr a shia cleric was millions of
followers and the large armed groups too
so he emerged as the big winner of this
vote um with 74 seats
and the second winner is once again the
same as 2018 vote nuri al-maliki
coalition state of law so we're still uh
watching this negotiation and realities
between these groups so we still don't
know who is going to to hold an alliance
okay thank you for that insight sophia
niti in baghdad
you